well the food pyramid as it stands today
doesn't even have any food on it you
have to have a computer and go on line
and then try to sort through everything
that's on the website in order to figure
out what it's advising and in that sense
it's it took away the new pyramid which
came out in 2005 took away the real
value of the old one the old one had
flaws but one of the thing it did one of
the things that did very well I think
was to indicate that it was better to
eat some foods than others better for
health and the no pyramid doesn't make
that point nearly as clearly
nutritionists tell me that they can't
use it that it's so difficult to teach
from to explain that they don't use it i
really don't know anybody who uses it to
teach or for any purpose whatsoever
you